you lost quite a bit of weight how much
weight did you lose
I lost 130 pounds that's like that's a
hard way yes drop the hard way yeah
that's weird when you say it that way I
know it I knew what I was doing okay so
run here's a question like I knew you I
think I knew you pretty well before you
lost the weight you've lost weight now
do do you prefer yourself now to the end
you how does it on the a difference I
hate it true you hate it I hate it I'm
so boring now like all I do is like work
out and eat normal foods like there's a
reason why fat people were jolly kkona
like now I can only eat things unlike my
cheat days and then that's I mean that's
like my best time like my best cheat day
was on New Year's Eve I went to a
wedding in Minneapolis and inside my
hotel there was a water park and inside
that water park there was a Dairy Queen
[Laughter]
you yeah you hit the jackpot now are you
doing anything else to take care of
yourself besides trying to keep the
staylene and eat well I do a little
maintenance
I got a stand an appointment to get my
manicure and my pedicure down at hammer
and nails hi girls
hammer and nails you got a manicure
pedicure yeah is that something you
always did yeah don't you know okay no
you know I I quit my own fingernails
like a commoner
I don't do a great job I literally just
like sometimes I look at my girl that's
awful and I just have a clipper but no I
would think getting is it nice to get a
manicure is wonderful then when I go to
is all guys so it's real cool and you
just sit back and you watch sports or
cartoons or the Great British Bake Off
like I do when I go and you just get
your nails done I always feel any part
of you that might go into your
significant other you need to take as I
understand it you were raised in a house
of all women yes yes sir and so do you
think that maybe helped open you up to
the concept of taking care of yourself
but yeah I think sometimes if people
grow up in a like an overly masculine
environment they think oh I can't go get
a massage I can't go get a manicure yeah
I think it definitely helped I was just
raised in a house with my mom my sister
my cousin and then her mom and that was
just all four girls in me and so I
played a lot of pretty pretty princess
and I learned you gotta I mean you got
to really be fierce to get that tiara
and so that kind of just sits with me
you know and that's part of the reason I
lost the weight is because I like
fashion I don't want to you know you're
fat all your shirts have like giant dogs
on them
I love those shirts they do have good
messages yeah do you get things like
massages and things like that
almost definitely I love to get a
massage I have a good spa day I like
bringing my friends with me it's just
really again just about taking care of
yourself you got wear makeup I feel I
don't know why guys are getting away
with not wearing makeup everybody looks
better what makeup it's just a job yeah
I wear I mean for the show I where they
hose me down human flesh color because
I'm so so white and they just have just
giant power hoses but it's actually the
part of the job I like the least cuz I
hate I hate getting makeup on and then I
hate taking it off after the show I just
live with it I never take it off just
keep it on and just look pretty I like
it I don't get your point
[Applause]
you